متاعب ترامب القانونيه تتجاوز ملف الوثائق
السريه فالرئيس السابق يواجه محاكمه في
منهات بولايه نيويورك لاتهامه بشراء صمت
الممثله ستورميدان قبل انتخابات 2016 في
مايو الماضي قضت محكمه في منهات بتغريم
الرئيس السابق مبلغ خمسه ملايين دولار في
الدعوه المدنيه التي رفعتها عليه الكاتبه
اي جين كارول بتهمه الاعتداء الجنسي
والتشهير وطالب ترامب باعاده المحاكمه وفي
ولايه جورجيا يواجه ترامب احتمال ان توجه
له فاني ويليس المدعيه العامه لمقاطعه
فولتون اتهامات بدعوى محاوله العمل على
الغاء نتائج انتخابات الولايه لعام 2020
بالعوده الى نيويورك سيمثل ترامب للمحاكمه
في اكتوبر المقبل بتهمه الاحتيال الضريبي
لمؤسسه ترامب
كما تجري وزاره العدل تحقيقا ربما يقود
لتوجيه اتهامات الى ترامب تشمل اتهامه
بالتحريض على اقتحام الكونجرس عام 2021
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات